one of the most powerful beings in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is on her way
to the big screen if you're unfamiliar
with the latest MCU headliner Carole
Captain Marvel Danvers here are a few
basic facts you're gonna want to keep in
mind as you settle in with your popcorn
Captain Marvel tells the story of Carol
Danvers played by Oscar winner brie
Larson unlike most MCU flicks the movie
isn't set in the present day but instead
takes place in the 90s
this gives Marvel plenty of time to show
Danvers becoming Captain Marvel and
explain why she was nowhere to be found
as the events of 2008 Ironman assured
him the MCU superhero age and why she
wasn't even referenced until the
post-credits scenes in 2018 infinity war
Danvers was first introduced as a
character in 1968 Marvel superheroes
number 13 she was a retired Air Force
pilot serving a supporting role for the
character Marvel who had been created a
year earlier and was then occupying the
role of Captain Marvel cutting out
decades of complicated comic-book
backstory the MCU seems to have decided
to streamline Danvers origins as they've
done more than once for the screen
versions of their classic characters in
the past one of the central forces in
Captain Marvel is a group that entered
the Marvel Comics universe way back in
1967 in Fantastic Four number 65 we're
talking about the Kree a technologically
advanced race of aliens that generally
take the form of blue skinned and purple
eyed beings with otherwise human
features they aren't necessarily bad
guys but they tend to have a bit of a
mixed reputation as they can be
militaristic and are infamous for their
constant squabbles around the galaxy
Danvers herself became a human crew
Hydra due to an accident that altered
her DNA and you're free a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior heroes but
the movie actually won't be the kree's
first foray into the MCU the ravager
yondu from guardians of the galaxy for
example revealed that he was sold to the
Kree in his youth Ronan the accuser was
also a rogue creed general that ignored
the treaty between his people and the
Nova Corps and attacked Xander with the
help of Thanos the blue skinned aliens
have also made a number of appearances
on ABC's agents of shield
while the Cree have a bit of a mixed
history their longtime enemies the
extraterrestrial race known as the
scrolls are far less complicated at
least as far as humans are concerned
their appearances in the comics usually
correlate with earth invasions or their
more distant and ancient quarrels with
the Kree the scrolls first appeared in
the comics in Fantastic Four number two
in 1962 making them slightly more
well-established than Danvers or the
Kree the most important thing you're
going to want to remember about the
scrolls is that they're shapeshifters
able to take on whatever appearance they
need in order to infiltrate and destroy
empires organizations and even herds of
superheroes causing distress and
distrust from the inside out this of
course means they could already be
involved in more than one MCU movie
infiltrating high positions and simply
biding their time for the perfect moment
to strike
and you thought Hydra was sneaky another
element of Carol Danvers Captain Marvel
comic book history is her ability to
take on her so-called binary form which
first appeared in the uncanny x-men
number 164 Danvers ability to transform
into the super-powered binary emerged
when yet another evil alien race known
as the brood abducted and experimented
on her further augmenting her already
significantly altered DNA as binary
Danvers could transform into an energy
manipulating state that allowed her to
lift more than 100 tons and fly it
nearly the speed of light and these
skills seemed to be in evidence in the
trailers in the third Captain Marvel
trailer we get a quick glimpse of Carol
suited up and leading a group of aliens
all dressed in the same uniform walking
in slow mode through an otherworldly
setting it doesn't last long but the
view is most likely our first look at
Star Force a team of warriors that fight
for the Kree the group was introduced in
the comics in Avengers number 346 in
1992 in the MCU we've already met one
Star Force member or Rath who appeared
as one of Ronan the accusers lackeys in
guardians of the galaxy spoiler alert in
an interview with Entertainment Tonight
samuel l.jackson who will be reprising
his role as Nick Fury in Captain Marvel
was asked if he thought Danvers was
worthy of being the first female MCU
character to get her own movie his
response was in essence a breakdown of
all her incredible powers including
this little tidbit Captain Marvel is one
of the few people in the Marvel Universe
that can time travel
hold the phone she can mutt time-travel
has been heavily rumored as one of the
main ways that the events of infinity
war could be undone but the context has
usually suggested that Ant Man would
somehow be using the quantum realm or
Doctor Strange would be using the time
stone needless to say the quote caused
an immediate ripple effect of rumors and
theories the question that remains is
how exactly danvers mysterious
time-traveling abilities will be
depicted in the film speaking of Nick
Fury the ex director of shield is
clearly going to play an important role
in Carol Danvers evolution into Captain
Marvel it's likely that the movie will
double not only as an origin story for
Carol Danvers but in a secondary
capacity one for Nick Fury as well from
showing his rise through the ranks of
shield to revealing why on earth his gut
instinct after the finger snap would be
tap aged Captain Marvel there are a lot
of fury based questions that could find
their answers in this one oh and he's
also shown in the trailer with two
healthy eyes so there's a good chance
we'll also see something regarding the
origin of that eye patch finally there's
goose the fuzzy little guys and just
tossed into a scene for a bit of comic
relief between the future head of shield
and a random feline it also happens to
be Carol Danvers pet and it's an alien
goose is a flirt c'n an alien species
that typically resembles terrestrial
cats with a couple of noticeable
exceptions for example they have a huge
array of tentacles that come out of
their mouths and they lay eggs at a
furious rate they also possess human
level intellect as well as pocket
realities of space and time within their
bodies so yeah
not your typical house cat in the comics
Danvers pet was named chewy but the name
has apparently been changed from the
famous movie wing man to another for the
MCU adding yet another nod to some
hardcore nostalgia in the process check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite MCU heroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]